welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Shazam
Fury of the Gods a follow-up to the 2019
DC film Shazam with a lot of fun cameos
Easter eggs and a Shameless Skittles
product placement that almost made me
run back out to concessions sir we were
told you to cut you off after four boxes
a bunch of crunch but our nature chased
our rainbow damn it let's break this
movie Down scene by scene and a reminder
to check out our new channel the Deep
dive where this Friday will be my
analysis of the 1989 Batman the best way
to support our growing network is to get
some of our merch at nerd riot.shop okay
Fury of the Gods opens with some Fury of
some gods in a museum by the Acropolis
in Athens where rizwan Manji plays a
very non-greek unlucky docent who
explains the history of the Wizard's
broken staff which remember Shazam Billy
snapped in half in the 2019 film and the
dose in here says it was found in a dump
outside Billy after breaking three trash
compactors two figures in Greek armor
March up the furies hespera Helen Mirren
and Calypso Lucy Liu Calypso tries to
press her hand through the glass casing
at first setting up Shazam encasing her
inside the Dome barrier year in the
final battle brain directly behind these
two in the middle is a statue of Atlas
their father in Greek mythology the
Hesperides were three nymphs of the
evening which is where hesper gets her
name whereas Calypso was a different
figure Calypso spelled with the c is
another daughter of Atlas who in The
Odyssey trapped Odysseus on an island
for seven years promising him
immortality but these three sisters are
not really in DC Comics they were
created for the film they and their
sister Anthea Rachel zegler are the
daughters of Atlas who represent the
last of the Gods in the DC Universe
because remember in the first Wonder
Woman movie we learned Ares killed off
all the other gods which looking back
was a bit of a bummer especially
considering how fun the gods were and
Zack Snyder's Justice League during the
ancient Dark Side battle these sisters
turned the museum attendees into caked
sand or clay and I just appreciate how
all their magic seems to be based on
Elemental Earthly materials like the
dragon as composed of wood later when
Shazam annihilates a tree everything
just turns into Dead Leaves it just
imbues their power with an ancient
Earthly quality Billy's therapist
pediatrician Dr Dario Baba is played by
PJ Byrne who plays the bot filmmaker
Adam board and the boys the toys in his
office included Cameo by Annabelle this
movie's director David F Sandberg also
directed Annabelle creation and included
an Annabelle cameo in the 2019 Shazam
film and that antique shop early in the
movie there are also Wonder Woman dolls
a Batman figurine literally DC Merchants
everywhere in this movie it's not even
worth pointing out at this point but in
the back there is a unicorn King of the
Beast s the really fun DC Easter eggs
here on the alphabet wall s for staro
the villain from The Suicide Squad t for
titano the Super 8 a Superman villain
and K for Kraken an ancient Beast bought
by Aquaman Billy it's confessing his
imposter syndrome comparing himself to
The Flash and Aquaman and Batman naming
them in the order of the next times we
will see these movies on the DC slate
The Flash coming June 2023 Aquaman the
last Kingdom coming December 2023 and
the next Matt Reeves Reverend Pattinson
Batman scheduled for October 2025. new
head of DC films James Gunn announced
their Gods and Monsters playing earlier
this year and at the moment it's kind of
tough to see how Shazam Fury and the
gods will fit into it if at all this
movie's post-credit scene shows Harcourt
and economos from Guns The Suicide Squad
and HBO Max's Peacemaker series
recruiting Shazam for the Justice
Society similar to Amanda Waller trying
to recruit Black Adam in that movie's
post-credits scene now so it seems like
there are a sizable number of DC fans
who are going after James good
constantly right now and Harcourt is
played by James Gunn's real life wife
Jennifer Holland Gunn did say that the
post-credits scene and the whole film
was shot before he took over DC in
December but he does have a peacemaker
spin-off series Waller in the works for
HBO Max and this could tie into that
either way it sounds like The Flash
movie this summer will reset the DC film
continuity with other universes left as
deliberate else worlds like the Pats and
Batman Universe and the Joaquin Phoenix
Joker universe so whether or not Shazam
is part of that really depends on how
well this movie does we return to the
family foster home with Freddie Eugene
Pedro Darla and Mary Darla is accused of
leaving Skittles in her pockets and she
makes a diorama of unicorns attacking
Genghis Khan or shadowing the Unicorn
charge in the Final Act which is fueled
by Skittles the Ambrosia of today which
is generous like have you tried the
butter beer at Wizarding World of Harry
Potter or the Cocoa Puff topped cold
brew at Galaxy's Edge yes obviously of a
sweet tooth I'm all cavities Grace
Caroline Curry plays both the normal
Mary Bromfield and the powered up Mary
the only one of the Shazam family did
not have an adult actor playing her
powered up form as Sandberg said that
she's already an adult now also Michelle
bork wasn't brought back from the first
film after some interesting political
Instagram posts the kids in this movie
are always wearing reference shirts like
Billy here wears a Goonies shirt as he's
really the Mikey of this Goonies crew
trying to keep them all together Goonies
Never Say Die ready just like in the
2019 film is always wearing shirts for
like Aquaman we see him wearing a Batman
and Robin shirt as a literal bat and
Robin at the end of the movie a gremlin
shirt he also wears a shirt with a tree
which you could see as a mirror of the
tree of life that the daughters of Atlas
are trying to regrow Eugene wears an
iconoclash shirt which is actually a
video game that David F sandberg's
brother made as they leave their home
walking out on the street on the fence
is torpa torpa is a school where
Sandberg and his wife Loda lost in met
whereas Yoon doll is written beneath it
that's a school they both transferred to
Sandberg said that this whole walk and
power-up shot was a pickup shot that
they had to do since originally they had
them power up off camera and for the
placeholder during test ratings they
actually use something that they shot
for the first movie and no one noticed
apparently the Philly Fiasco's power up
to save the people on the bridge the
woman in the car is actually Cameo by
samberg's wife Lota she stars in all of
their amazing horror shorts on the pony
Smasher YouTube channel including lights
out which this movie later references by
someone's saying lights out and the
credits she's listed as nurse in need of
a hero as here she sings Bonnie Tyler's
I need a hero obviously Sandberg worked
in a lot of references to his life and
his friends and his horror influences
later on in the movie on one of the
streets Shazam is standing in front of a
shop that reads balchi an homage by
Sandberg to Italian film director Lucio
falchi but here on the bridge the family
struggles to cooperate powered up Freddy
refers to himself as Captain every Power
in Billy as Captain every Power Junior
she's a running joke for how they don't
really have superhero names yet in the
confusion of shazam's real name
historically in DC Comics being Captain
Marvel before Marvel came in and just
basically ripped off that name so DC the
new 52 just basically had to rename him
as Shazam it's always been very
confusing but in the comics when he went
by Captain Marvel Freddy was Captain
Marvel Jr so they're just kind of
reversing it here big debrief in the
rock of Eternity which they have turned
into their Clubhouse I love how the back
wall of The Rock has turned into a rock
climbing wall Freddie hangs newspaper
clippings including one of Wonder Woman
setting up Diana's Cameo later not that
surprising because Warner Brothers put
it in all of their trailers pretty much
then in the room of doors Eugene has
gone through many of the doors seeing
which ones are not okay to go into one
is a signed warning beware of spider dog
another one nightmare fuel M for Mature
Eugene gets thrown out of one covered in
slime saying do not go in there which
feels like an Ace Ventura reference do
not go in there whoa
Billy says Wonder Woman doesn't have a
job joking that she doesn't wear
ponytail in glasses and work as an
accountant and not to Diana's day job as
a museum archivist in Paris and Elena
Carter TD Wonder Woman when she played
Diana Prince hesper and Calypso forced
an imprisoned wizard to repair the staff
but he keeps a splinter that he uses to
summon Billy at their High School from
the last movie Freddy meets and AKA
Anthea and a few bullies and like in the
2019 film Freddy just gets his ass
kicked this kid walks with a crutch they
Bend his crutch this is some real hate
crime and I know the Philly Flyers
GM's son loves to do this kind of stuff
but can we have some consequences for
people in movies to attack people with
disabilities and not just write it off
as typical bullying like the teacher
just checks in with him afterwards like
hey you okay kid and not going after the
bullies to expel them what is this the
50s come on Dietrich Vader plays this
teacher and this actor is actually voice
Batman and a number of animated titles
including the recent Harley Quinn series
and I love how in the background of the
scene there's just it's a little detail
but I think it's very funny there's a
drama club poster with we need more boys
not and my High School drama club I was
the only boy they needed used to get all
the parts until our teachers started
recruiting Jackson's wrestling team to
play the leads now we work crazy hours
to get these videos out to you as soon
as we can our lunch hours can be more
like our lunch 15 minutes luckily we
have some hopsco e-bikes in the office
to ZIP down the street to grab some food
from a nearby restaurant ahovsko e-bike
can go up to 28 miles per hour with
pedal assist the bike has a range of up
to 60 miles throttle only and up to 80
if you don't mind pumping your legs a
bit even if you live in hilly hilly San
Francisco like I do uphill riding is
still smooth and easy the hills of San
Francisco have met their match with the
torque sensor pedal assist great for
starting from stop on a hill also very
very fun the high quality 88 volt
Samsung LG lithium battery will keep
your bike and your flashlight going and
they're a blast to ride folks in the
office are always fighting for who gets
to ride to pick up lunch all hopsco
e-bikes come with a two-year warranty
and free shipping and right now they are
having a sale on some of their most
popular models if you enter promo code
Rockstar 100 at checkout you'll get an
addition National 100 off your purchase
there's never been a better time to get
an e-bike and hopsco is hooking us up
head to hopsco.com to find the bike
that's right for you and don't forget to
use promo code Rockstar 100 for an
additional 100 off your purchase Billy
has a dream where he's on a date with
Wonder Woman in Paris and we only ever
see her from behind here like the
Superman faceless cameo in the 2019 film
but this is not actually Gal Gadot here
this is a stand-in model Taylor Cahill
and the Wizards face astral projects on
her head in the dream I hope this
doesn't awaken anything in me but back
in the rock of Eternity Billy references
a violin that's constantly burning this
comes from the comics when the villain
Ogar enchants Nero's fiddle to
constantly release fire nearly burns
down the city of New York they read up
on the daughters of Atlas in the tree of
life in the archives where they meet
their friend Steve a pen and we learned
that the Wizards used the staff card
from the Tree of Life to steal the power
of the Gods and they created a sphere
that encased the gods away from our
realm now Shazam Billy doesn't know how
to pronounce Solomon he says solo man is
it just me or is he like weirdly dumb in
this movie dumber than a 17 year old
should be dumber than he was in the 2019
just often feels like Zachary Levi is
playing up the stupidity and playing a
version of Billy that Asher Angel isn't
really playing Tom Hanks in big and in
Forrest Gump worked really hard to study
the mannerisms and speech patterns of
the kids whose adult versions he played
and Levi seemed to be doing that in the
2019 film but here it's like he's doing
a new campy stick and going more for
laughs and it doesn't really seem to be
that authentic that's just me though
Freddie and Anne hang out on the rooftop
and Freddy Powers up but in this moment
he gets attacked by hespera and Calypso
philipso makes poor Mr Jacob walk off
the edge and says I forgot how easily
they burst like grapes that's horrifying
the Shazam family arrives to help but
the sister's get away with Freddy
leaving Shazam stuck on the other side
of the barrier they take Freddy back to
their Atlas Temple where Clips so tries
to force them to tell the truth about
who the other Champions are but he
screams Destiny's Child did it better
and I gotta say it's pretty nice of a
kid who's probably based off the
timeline of this movie born in the early
OTS who's only ever grown up in the
reign of Beyonce as a solo act to pay
some respect to Kelly Rowland and
Michelle Williams though at the same
time a trio of women that includes Lucy
Liu it's just a surprise that Charlie's
Angels never came up here hespera reads
a letter that Steve dictated for them on
the magical parchment it's pretty
hilarious to hear Helen Mirren read it
word for word reminding me of when she
had to recite the full name of Borat
when she presented at the Oscars Sasha
Baron Cohen for Borat cultural learnings
of America for make benefit glorious
nation of Kazakhstan based on characters
created by Sasha Baron Cohen Brady and
The Wizard get thrown into Calypso's pit
where the dragon nearly burns them but
Anthea uses her powers to manipulate
space to relocate them and help them
Escape Shazam Billy has a summit with
espera outside Sam's Philly cheesesteaks
where a guy calls him Colonel
Cheesesteak another Captain Marvel joke
there Billy says that he's seen all the
Fast and Furious movies and he knows
it's all about family which does feel
like another Helen mirror nod for her
role as Queenie Shaw in those movies
Shazam Billy again mistakes Solomon
saying he has the wisdom of Saruman
Saruman from Lord of the Rings so he
knows who that is but not Solomon they
have a fight with espera they throw each
other around there's parallel shot
composition where hesper lifts Shazam to
body slam him and then he does the same
to this woman at the end of the fight
they end up imprisoning her in the lair
but big mistake because she escapes and
steals that a black coated Apple that
we've been seeing throughout these
scenes turns out this is exactly the
seed they're looking for one of the
golden apples from the tree of life and
they use this to replant at Citizens
Bank Park as the roots snake through the
city pods hatch releasing classical
mythological monsters manticores those
are the Lions with wings and Stinger
Tails Cyclops those are the one-eyed
horned ogres minotars of course the
bullheaded boys and harpies those are
the female face shrieking monsters one
of these Philadelphia residents who gets
lifted off the ground and tossed is a
cameo by director David F Sandberg the
family meets atop the parking garage and
Rosa has a sweet home with Billy selling
them always have a home with them Billy
Shazam confronts Calypso on her Dragon
calling her hey Khaleesi and during this
fight he gets hit with a black toxic
sludge and he's thrown to the street
below where a local Shazam fan says
you're the best Captain Marvel this is
actually a cameo by Michael Gray who
played Billy Batson in the 70s TV series
Darla uses Ambrosia of Skittles to
attract a herd of unicorns who mow down
the other monsters and Charlotte screams
Taste the rainbow which
almost makes the product placement worth
it I think Calypso's Dragon kills
hespera and nearly kills Anthony and
ready stands at her side but Billy's
able to grab the tail and ends up
trapping Calypso and the dragon in a
shrunken version of the Dome just around
the tree of life in Citizens Bank Park
hesper had told him that his lightning
would annihilate everything inside the
Dome so it's a showdown on the field
between Billy and the dragon Billy uses
that stat to impale the dragon against a
tree screaming Shazam wiping out all the
magic and the life inside the Dome and
killing all three of them they end up
holding Billy's funeral at the temple a
place that it's not entirely clear how
they got to since there's no magic
currently in the world so however they
got there they were dragging Billy
Batson's corpse coffin flopping it all
over the streets of Philly
the wizard says they need a God to
respark the staff and Diana appears with
the amazing Wonder Woman theme music
which is awesome I'm always gonna rock
out to it though let's remember we are
at a child's funeral right now a little
bit of an awkward needle drop so they
resurrect Billy he's got a dead spider
in his teeth Diana's like stick to
saving the world kid and like in a fast
and furious movie we end up with a
family dinner scene and The Wizard shows
up with a new look he finally tells
Billy his actual superhero name it's
Shazam but we end with Freddy saying I
think we can do better now the
postcarded scenes do have Billy getting
recruited by hardcore and economos to
join the Justice Society and her old
friend Dr Savannah from the 2019 film
still with Mr mind and is holding cell
just like in that past movies
post-credits scene there's nothing new
to report but remember Mr mine did lead
the first ever super villain team in DC
Comics The Monster Society of evil
whether or not these post-credit scenes
lead do anything in DC's future Beyond
an episode of Waller on HBO Max remains
to be seen and look I know this movie
isn't perfect a lot of people are giving
it a hard time that Rotten Tomato score
is looking a little rough but you know
what I still had fun watching this movie
I missed the era where superhero movies
can just be fun outings with superheroes
goofing off and not be the best
superhero movie of all time but hey
that's just where we are now everything
has to matter a reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eat a boss follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
foreign
[Music]